Zack Snyder’s Justice League’s convoluted
production process and the fan campaigns for
its release have made it a particularly interesting
specimen in the already pretty fascinating
superhero movie genre, and to make the most
of a unique situation, Snyder seemingly used
every opportunity to cram the four-hour film
full of neat stuff.
There are numerous changes from the theatrical
version and cool Easter eggs – and even
a brand new epilogue scene that teases a grim,
apocalyptic future in which a potty-mouthed
Batman and a long-haired, weary Joker team
up to battle an evil Superman.
Among the many new characters the Snyder Cut
brings into the fold is Darkseid, the interplanetary
warlord behind the movie's main villain, Steppenwolf.
Darkseid drops by near the end of the movie,
rocking up to the action with his two major
lieutenants flanking him.
The creepy, robed guy on the tyrant's right-hand
side is Desaad, Darkseid's sadistic assistant.
But who's the white-haired old lady rounding
up the trio?
And as a fair warning, try not to laugh at
her name.
The lady in question is Granny Goodness, a
perennial contender for the worst misnomer
in the entire DC universe.
She may look like a sweet old lady, and her
name may suggest that's entirely true, but
she's anything but.
This granny won't bake you cookies and slip
a $20 bill into your bag after you visit her
"just in case you need pocket money" — oh
no, she'll mess your whole life up while keeping
a smile on her face.
Created by comic book legend Jack Kirby, who's
credited both as the writer and artist behind
the character, Granny Goodness made her DC
Comics debut in 1971's Mister Miracle Vol.
1 #2.
She's a New God originating from the planet
Apokolips, and started off as a member of
the "Lowlies" class.
When she was plucked from the peasants around
her to become a "Hound" for Darkseid, Granny
Goodness' life and fate changed.
She established herself as an incredibly ruthless,
manipulative, and dangerous woman as she became
the trainer and commander of Darkseid's elite
forces — a job that she accomplishes by
brainwashing innocent orphans into obedient
killing machines in his "orphanage" facilities.
What's worse, her torturous training methods
and unrepentant, sadistic nature are directly
contradicted by her gentle, sweet manner.
Granny Goodness even takes her appearance
from that of the late comedian and actress
Phyllis Diller, who wouldn't hurt a fly unless
she could make it laugh beforehand.
Basically, imagine Dolores Umbridge from the
Harry Potter film franchise, add superpowers
and elite military training in place of magic,
and equip her with several torture dungeons
and battalions of elite troops she has at
her disposal.
That's Granny Goodness.
What little we see of Granny in Zack Snyder's
Justice League makes her seem like a more
physically imposing figure than her comic
book counterpart.
And while the Snyder Cut of Justice League
does mark Granny Goodness' live-action film
debut, it's not the first time she's appeared
in the flesh on viewers' screens.
That happened just once prior, in the penultimate
season of the CW superhero series Smallville,
starring Tom Welling as Clark Kent in his
years living in Kansas before he becomes Superman.
Two different actresses portrayed Smallville's
Granny, and the depiction of the character
leaned pretty heavily on the sinister end
of the sweet-old-lady-ruthless-manipulator
dichotomy.
In Smallville, Nancy Amelia Bell brought Granny
Goodness to life in the season 9 finale, "Salvation,"
in which her face isn't seen but the markers
of her outwardly sweet side — knitting needles
and a cozy, covered-up outfit — were.
Christine Willes took over the role thereafter,
making her the literal face of Smallville's
Granny — the prim and proper Head Administrator
of St. Louise's Orphanage who's secretly a
cunning master manipulator with powerful telepathic
and telekinetic abilities, along with a number
of other powers.
A season 10 episode reveals that one of the
children at St. Louise's Orphanage was Tess
Mercer, who – spoiler alert — is really
Lutessa Luthor, the daughter Lionel Luthor
had with Pamela Jenkins, his son Lex's nanny.
Tess lived at the orphanage from the time
she was five years old to when her biological
father returned and took Tess out of Granny
Goodness' care.
Before Tess left, Granny erased nearly all
of her memories so that she wouldn't remember
her life before the Mercers adopted her.
We’re not sure if there will be a sequel
to Synder’s Justice League, but if anyone
wants to make use of the character in future
projects, Granny Goodness would certainly
make for a menacing, scheming villain that
would scare just about anyone who crosses
her path.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC villains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.